-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
I'm going to get to the news.
A Manhattan jury on Friday
ordered former President Trump
to pay nearly $84 million
in his civil defamation case.
Well, that explains
the new fundraising amounts.
Former President Trump said
at a rally in Las Vegas
over the weekend that he feels,
quote, "Sharper now
than I did 20 years ago."
Of course, based on
all of his testimony,
he doesn't remember a single
thing from 20 years ago.
The White House is set to hold
a live streamed event tomorrow
with high school students.
The event is called
Seniors for Seniors.
The Biden campaign is reportedly
hoping to get an endorsement
from Taylor Swift,
though personally,
I think they're going
about it all wrong.
When asked in an interview
yesterday
about former President Trump's
false birther attacks
against her,
presidential candidate
Nikki Haley said, quote,
"When he feels threatened,
he starts to throw all kinds
of things out there."
Said Trump,
"She's sleeping with Fauci."
California Governor Gavin Newsom
said in an interview yesterday
that Democrats have done
a much better job
in recent months of
selling their accomplishments,
and added that the party
has the receipts
from three years
of the Biden administration.
Because,
like most guys his age,
Biden's been keeping
all of them in his wallet.
"Yeah, you never know.
You never know
when you're going
to need a receipt
to prove you bought something.
Just -- Just keep it with you.
Keep it in your wallet."
In a new interview,
Republican Senator Tim Scott
said that average Americans
are, quote,
"Not talking about the lawsuits
against former President Trump."
You know what else
they're not talking about?
[Whispers] Tim Scott.
Russian President Vladimir Putin
was formally registered today
for the upcoming election
in March.
And I've seen enough --
with zero precincts reporting,
I'm calling it for Putin.
A man in -- [ Laughs ]
A man in California
recently set
the Guinness World Record
for largest collection
of hotel keycards,
and in a very related story,
they finally caught
the Sacramento Strangler.
I felt the same way
when I read it.
It makes you laugh at first,
and then you're like, "Oh, God."
Climate activists
at the Louvre in Paris
over the weekend threw
pumpkin soup on the Mona Lisa,
though I think it's
a little off message
to go after a lady
who didn't even have a car.
Oh. Is that --
Was that the issue?
Oh, what was --
That joke was cut?
Oh, interesting. Yeah.
Well, I -- Well, I can't say
we were proven wrong.
So I'm sorry -- So there's
a lot wrong with it,
but was the issue that the ring
thing was up the whole time?
That was one of the issues?
Yeah, yeah.
Certainly going to be
an interesting meeting
after the show.
I hope at least there's one
person there who's like,
"I thought it went good."
The doorbell security camera
company Ring --
Do we want to go
to the next graphic,
or do we want to keep this?
The doorbell security camera
company Ring announced last week
that it would no longer
allow police departments
to request users' footage,
but then reminded customers
that they do still have
a binding contract
with "America's
Funniest Home Videos."
A French tourist at Arkansas's
Crater of Diamonds State Park
recently found
a seven carat diamond.
Wow, that is hard to believe --
someone in France
took a vacation to Arkansas?
The locals must have been
super psyched
when they found the diamond.
[French accent]
"Oh, look at this."
[ Speaking gibberish ]
[ Sighs ] Just a lot --
A lot's happened
this monologue.
I just feel like --
I mean, it's almost over,
but I feel like
we've been through a lot.
And finally, a Russian man who
flew from Denmark to Los Angeles
without a passport last year
was found guilty last week
of being a stowaway
and faces up to five years
in prison or worse,
a return flight
on Alaska Airlines.
You guys!
I feel like
a couple more weeks --
a couple more weeks where
that'll be a fair punchline.
You guys, that was a monologue.
We made it. We made it through.